un charbon soit bien le bonsoir alors
elle chef jamais ça vous êtes
confortable dans ce rôle
la partie campagne électorale comme tel
rôle de chef c'est encore assez nouveau
c'est quand tu sais plus où tu es
qu'elle ne riez quel jour on est tué
c'est totalement nouveau là la
familiarité que l'appareil médias ça se
passe bien il ya de bons souvenirs à
l'appareil médias qui me qui vous mène
une zone de confort qui me reviennent
qui me permet des interventions coquine
parfois je peux pas passer la sphère
faire notre vie sans vous parler de la
sphère d'un justin trudeau vous a pas
fait théâtre par a cogné règles ont
changé sujet sans jamais arriver le mois
deux mois de crise aiguë depuis mon tout
jeune âge vraisemblablement pas jamais
avec de la couleur au visage de quelques
façons que ce soit mais sur ce beau jeu
on a probablement tout sauf des
niaiseries dans de jeunesse peut-être
même les animateurs a débuté une
nouvelle dont la toute jeune agnès
décembre virement bons maîtres il faut
doser sur la fréquence et la nature des
niaiseries et le moment et la manière de
l'admettre
parce que je disais tout à l'heure que
vous avez eue hier soir la réaction la
plus mesuré j'avais dit c'est peut-être
un très mauvais premier ministre mais
quand même il n'y est pas resté ce
monsieur j'ai besoin qu'il ya tous les
défauts et on a inventé quelques anges
d'hôtes hautement de ces qualifications
pour être premier ministre d'un pays du
g7 mais toute sa vie tout son passé
récent toutes ses habitudes ses
comportements c'est valence évolutions
font produits en reste ils font produire
un bon représentant de la nation
québécoise clairement il faut produire
insiste donc c'est pas un filon que vous
aller exploiter pour les prochains jours
au québec dans votre campagne
il ya une partie de moi qui ont envie
qui éventuellement on passe un peu à
autre chose moi j'aimerais avoir justin
trudeau sur le terrain de la campagne
électorale pour devoir répondre à des
questions se prononcer sur des enjeux
pour que les québécois façon choix là on
a un premier ministre qui va devoir nous
faire sa 77e son 77e acte de contrition
je m'excuse mais que les seules
personnes aux prises sans pression que
prédit qu'elle ne se soit pas excusé
c'est les québécois en 1978 les acadiens
mais tout le reste on passe un moment
donné une colonne vertébrale ça serve à
la fonction premier ministre et c'est
pas sa plus grande qualité je sais pas
si vous l'avez entendu aujourd'hui vous
dit il en a fait trop
aujourd'hui dans les excuses mais c'est
pas trop dans les excuses et il s'est
mis dans tellement de situations il ya
des fois où il s'excuse parce qu'il a
fait une niaiserie et des fois où il
s'excuse parce que politiquement c'est
bien de s'excuser auprès des soins
auprès des autres le mouchoir et pas
très loin
éventuellement ça le rattrape le manque
de sérieux et l'instrumentalisation de
de s'excuser de quelque chose qui
éventuellement tu arrives en campagne
électorale et là arrive un autre
scandale et c'est la goutte qui fait
déborder le vase c'est la fois de trop
celle là les racines profondes dans une
crédibilité qui était déjà mise à mal
très bien vous parlez de choses qui
peuvent rattraper des chefs
la question lancinante quand on parle du
bloc québécois pour les chefs du bloc
québécois c'est l'utilité du bloc
québécois l'offre politique dans un jeu
fédérale au québec fait que inverse peut
voter vers quelqu'un qui veut une
assurance dentaire au médicament a peu
voté npd quelqu'un qui veut voter
libéral vote libéral quelqu'un qui n'est
pas déficit vote conservateur pourquoi
les québécois voteraient pour le bloc
alors qu'on le sait prendrai jamais le
pauvre en fait on n'a pas l'aspiration
avant de pouvoir mais le québec et le
québec a été représenté à plusieurs
reprises pendant beaucoup d'années par
une majorité de députés québécois qui
venait du bloc québécois ça a été les
meilleures années pour le québec de la
fédération canadienne ça a été le grand
désert pour nous sous une majorité npd
au québec où avec le gouvernement
trudeau n'y a pas de gain pour le québec
apaq progression pour le québec et même
du recul pour le québec dans un certain
nombre de dossiers
l'autre élément c'est que les québécois
qui soit souverainiste ou pas la brière
est ce le tiers des québécois à peu près
qu'il soignait c'est une option qui
mériterait toujours d'être défendus et
en qui la souveraineté du québec ne sera
pas réalisée le bloc carottes toujours
une pertinence parce que c'est sa
vocation
alors on ne met jamais de côté une
option qui est encore considéré comme
souhaitable par le tiers de la
population d'un territoire
première chose deuxième chose mais il
est comme les gimmicks puisque vous en
parlez comme les québécois actuellement
non palatin
a décidé souveraineté ou pas ce n'est
pas dans l'agenda politique c'est pas
plus dur pour vous d'aller les
convaincre de voter bloc je peux je n'ai
pas mesuré le niveau de difficulté avant
d'entreprendre la vie l aventure de la
direction du bloc s'en sort je leur ai
probablement pas entreprises qui se
qualifie à l'époque ont fréquenté les
chroniques nécrologiques le faut se
rappeler un an
cependant la logique d'un vote pour le
bloc s'est beaucoup celle ci il en
revenant les québécois se sont donnés le
gouvernement
il aperçoit une vraie manne nationaliste
décomplexée extraordinairement
nationaliste normalement nationalisme et
sans complexe on avait pris ça au québec
depuis le début des années 2000 parce
que l'épisode avec madame marois dont
j'ai fait partie
mon état minoritaire donc on avait les
mains liées sur beaucoup de dossiers
alors un gouvernement arrive il est
normalement nationalistes plus proche
d'un robert bourassa que d'un
souverainiste à bien des égards et nous
ont dit ce que les québécois ont voulu à
québec et on n'ira pas le détruire à
ottawa parce que tous les partis
fédéralistes sont opposés à ce que
l'essence même des valeurs de l'actuelle
l'assemblée nationale du québec donc
vous voulez surfer passez moi
l'expression sur la vague de françois
legault vous êtes un peu son porte voix
à ottawa beaucoup plus que défenseur de
la souveraineté à ottawa en fait je ne
surfe pas parce que surfer sur quelque
chose ça me plaisait s'installer de
façon superficielle sur des valeurs qui
sont pas nécessairement les nôtres or le
nationalisme québécois la nécessité de
récupérer les migrations la protection
du français la laïcité les toqués de
clinton avait dit c'est bien fait mais
les demandes de françois legault sont
des choses qui incidemment était déjà
dans le programme du bloc et pourquoi
est ce qu'elle était dans le programme
du bloc et dans les demandes de françois
legault
parce que c'est la convergence naturelle
l'opposition nationale et nationalistes
pour l'équipe b là où il attend vous
avez dix douze treize députés l'abord 14
joueurs de 32 monsieur legault parle
fait des demandes à tahoua qu'est-ce que
ça va changer pour les québécois que
vous soyez 12 14 ou 15 là bas ça change
largement quelque chose dans ce site que
tu peux pas demander à ton assemblée à
ton parlement à québec de prendre des
orientations clairement choisi par les
québécois le 1er octobre est envoyé à
ottawa des gens qui vont voter pour le
contraire faire le contraire ou même
utiliser l'argent des québécois pour
faire le contraire la loi sur la laïcité
le plus bel exemple
la grande majorité des québécois est
favorable à la loi sur la laïcité
ouais tous les partis fédéralistes son
compte la loi sur la laïcité et l'on
s'apprête qui sait ce qui va arriver
parce que la réponse de haut en
interview de repos ça dure pas longtemps
on s'apprête à avoir l'argent les taxes
et les impôts des québécois qui vont
être utilisés pour lutter contre une loi
ce chien s'est engagé à ne pas le faire
mais je sais aussi monsieur senoussi
monsieur tron mais sans passer par les
autres qui le font
ce sont des organisations qui existe
déjà et qui sont déjà financés pour ce
même gouvernement fédéral qui prennent
cet argent là qui viennent notamment de
nos poches et qui l'utilisent pour
soutenir des citoyens qui conteste la
loi
c'est pour ça qu'ils peuvent dire moi je
ferais pas ça c'est quelqu'un d'autre
faire le place mais avec notre argent
oui la loi 21 avant de tester devant les
tribunaux avec ou sans l'aide du
gouvernement fédéral a volé de l'argent
y at il des lois et touchant monsieur
blanchet je pense que pour de loin tout
ça mais je pense qu'un parlement élu ne
doit pas aller contre la volonté de
l'eau parlement élu ayant un seul
parlement national pour les québécois
c'est l'assemblée nationale du québec
l'autre c'est pas un parlement national
et le parlement fédéral dans lequel des
gens de différentes orientations se
retrouvent pour certain que ça va être
la cour suprême qui va m il est
vraisemblable que çà et là ça aussi
c'est un dossier dont il faut qu'on le
traite faucon la botte pour des gens
comprennent une position il faut qu'on
revienne
est ce que tout le monde dit qu'il est
l'enjeu fondamental de cette campagne là
c'est à dire l'environnement puis plus
précisément dans mon corps la création
de richesse pour les québécois à partir
d'un modèle environnemental
mais justement il ya une grosse
manifestation la semaine prochaine ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont là vous serez
là j'imagine je vais marchand écoutez
madame grembert que peut-être on verra
un québécois qui veut qui se dit moi
c'est la sela en jeu qui me préoccupe
pourquoi votre impôt vert parce que le
parti vert est moins que le juste que le
parti que le bloc québécois marc r non
c'est intéressant j'adore la question
j'adore la question parce que enfin
tranché le bloc c'est facile moi je
pourrais dire que je suis extraterrestre
oui oui je vais vous le prouver alizée
les verts sont pour l'exploitation du
sable bitumineux
les vaches sont pour la transformation
en alberta du pétrole issu des sables
bitumineux
les verts sont pour l'heure dix ans pour
dire son voeu exaucé 0 les versions nous
arrêter tout demain n'aurais tu pas tout
de même fait une régression rapide de ça
nous aurons s'excuser ou l'augmentation
garder mon truc on va cesser la
circulation ou ne pas permettre
l'augmentation de la circulation de
pétrole des sables bitumineux travers le
territoire québécois parce que quand on
a dit oui mais vous en avez besoin
mais c'est pas vrai on en a pas besoin
tout ce qu'ils veulent faire passer au
québec strictement pour l'exportation
on est approvisionné on l'est depuis
qu'un certain mais lise l'environnement
autorisé l'inversion de la ligne 9
grecque mais tout ça elle le dit sommes
même allés mais aussi indiqué qu'aucun
nouveau peuple npa la digue dans 10 ans
ce qui est vous allez convenir monsieur
blanchet avec moi hautement joël poli
improbable que dans dix ans et du
pétrole au canada je pense qu'il est
hautement improbable qui ait plus de
pétrole au canada dans dix ans en effet
je pense qu'il faut établir un
échéancier sur d'ici 30 ans du baisse de
3% par année
l'extinction utilisé entre temps comptes
inexacts et sanogo a traversé le québec
ce n'est pas notre modèle ce n'est pas
une division et on pourrait prendre
l'argent que monsieur trudeau prend au
québec le 4 milliards de l'argent des
québécois qui va s'en aller dans france
mantle et l'utiliser pour développer nos
régions nos centres de recherche notre
modèle économique nos pme pour des
technologies environnementales nous
prépare chez d'exportation les régions
du québec
vous souhaitez vous l'avez dit un
gouvernement minoritaire pour que les
députés du bloc est le plus pouvoir
possible
ça ressemble à ça vous choisissez un
gouvernement rouge ou bleu
minoritaire en fait je n'ai pas choisi
le gouvernement souhaite double je n'ai
pas dit que je souhaitais j'ai dit que
j'accepterai que ça se produit je ne
demande pas aux québécois de faire en
sorte autres pour l'instant je verrai
pour la suite qui est un gouvernement
minoritaire parce que ça m'appartient
pas même si les québécois décident de
nous confier ce mandat là on a
l'obligation d'être fin prêt pour
relever le défi
mais demander ça à ce stade si au début
de la campagne aura un manque de
modestie de la part d'un parti qui est
quand même une période aussi facile que
ça on va regarder la campagne à lyon va
progresser mais il est clair que si tel
était le choix des québécoises et des
québécois
il serait capable d'obtenir des gains
substantiels pourquoi parce que quand
c'est pas bon pour le québec on votre
compte
quand c'est bon pour le québec on vote
pour et entre les deux on négocie des
positions favorables aux québécois et
donc vous souhaitez infanticide de profs
politique mais le niveau de confiance
que les gens vont nous accorder ça ça
leur appartient il faut avoir l'humilité
de ça ça vous a party on va on va faire
une offre politique qui ne se repent
qu'une dénonciation du gouvernement qui
va avoir beaucoup d'éléments qu'on ne
fait d'un derniers jours
l'électrification du transport scolaire
l'accessibilité aux véhicules
électriques parce que les jeunes
familles dit j'ai pas que je parte pas
d'impayés sont mis en place ou de
proposer des mesures pour seul soit on
travaille sur leur retrait du pétrole
ont fait des propositions très positive
et très concrètes vous appelez autant
les souverainistes que les fédéralistes
à voter pour vous ça vous avez dit
nationale non je ne vais pas parler ma
soeur parce que d'un entre maintenant et
le moment où l'assemblée nationale du
québec soit dans des dispositions
d'esprit pour reprendre le processus
vers la souveraineté qu'un ça va
appartenir la prochaine élection au
laser josh gorges est pas le faire on
faisait là on verra le proverbial on
verra bien dans l'intervalle il y a un
besoin pour la nation québécoise d'avoir
une voix moi je pense que des nationales
et chez les libéraux et des
nationalistes et québec solidaire des
nationalistes à l'aquarium du québec
c'est très clair et on suppose que tout
le monde parce québécois nationalistes
c'est une voix on est les seuls à être
national et son et les seuls à défendre
la laïcité on est des seuls à défendre
le modèle environnemental québécois on
est les seuls à défendre le français au
québec on est les seuls à défendre la
dvi ya un ensemble de dossiers pour
lesquels on est seul et je pense que les
québécois peuvent se reconnaître dans
cette offre politique là monsieur
blanchet bonne fin de campagne
au revoir aux abords des jeunes oui on
se voit aux débats qui auront eu débat
avant pour vous et on va sentir le que
ça va décoller pour l'intérêt des gens
oui on sortait vous sur le terrain que
les gens veulent entendre parler de
l'accueil c'est pas de malade il mais ça
s'en vient bien lionel terray là c'est
bien monsieur l'achat merci merci par
mois